Bueno ahora mismo estamos con el 97%
escrutado según la agencia de noticias
gubernamental con este escrutinio con
esta contabilización de votos el partido
el perdón el candidato ahí Perdón
estaría con un 49% del apoyo popular por
su parte el líder opositor que Malú
estaría con cerca de un 45% y el tercer
candidato sin anuar con un 5% por lo
tanto aún no se puede dar por seguro que
iríamos a unas segunda a una segunda
vuelta tampoco se puede dar por seguro
que hoy habría un candidato que ganaría
estas elecciones por lo tanto la
incerteza sigue aquí en Turquía con los
votos aún contabilizándose y al ver como
usted lo decía todavía en medio de una
cierta incertidumbre habló
erdogan sin embargo qué dijo Cuáles
fueron las claves de su discurso
cierto han hecho un discurso bastante en
clave ganadora erdoganna elogiado la
democracia que hay en Turquía debido a
un proceso de Voto producido hoy mismo
en que un 88% de los turcos han votado
para él esto ya ha sido una victoria de
la nación también ha dicho que no
descarta incluso ganar en la primera
vuelta puesto que dice que van liderando
estas elecciones unas elecciones donde
él también ha recordado que no ha
finalizado el proceso de Voto también se
ha referido al parlamento diciendo que
su partido ha ganado la mayoría en el
parlamento algo que según la agencia de
noticias gubernamental no es así puesto
que tienen un 49%
por lo tanto también ha querido
comunicar a su gente que teniendo una
mayoría una hipotética mayoría en el
parlamento no ve porque no debería ganar
estas elecciones presidenciales también
el candidato opositor que Malú sea ha
hecho un escueto comunicado en el que ha
dicho que hay millones de votos que aún
no han sido contabilizados y que
justamente esos votos irían del lado
opositor